what's the last thing you'd expect Kim
Kardashian to reveal that she's studying
to become a lawyer
that's right Khloe Kardashian's sister
is apprenticed at a law firm likely
triggered by her successful involvement
in getting Trump to pardon Alice Murray
Johnson the 63 year old woman jailed for
years on nonviolent drug charges and I
say why not
after all if this person can become a
lawyer and this person can become a
lawyer and this person could become a
lawyer and I say person loosely
why can't Kim she's got more sense than
all of them combined by the way avenatti
just got his five million dollar private
jet confiscated what's that tell you
that this litigating lollipop had 5
million bucks and spent it on a private
jet the point lawyers get away with
everything because they know how to get
around everything avenatti only got
caught because the media's roach motel
drew him out of the nooks and crannies
where he did his dirty work
CNN and MSNBC put that creep on TV a
zillion times only because they thought
he was just like them maybe they were
right look we should all become lawyers
because if you look at life it's
basically a game of Monopoly and lawyers
are the people who write the
instructions and actually take a few
minutes to read them without a law
degree we're just saps so instead of
mocking Kim for bringing a little
boom-boom to the courtroom we should
follow her lead and let her rest her
case wherever she was Emily you claim to
be a lawyer and I don't doubt it for one
second you talk like a lawyer very fast
very fast you read everything the small
print you know what's going on in this
world I'm scared of you I'm okay on this
that wasn't a question
oh I think wreck me about her rose means
for this and first of all she's not
going to Law School she is undertaking a
four-year apprenticeship with a law firm
after the first year she takes a mini
bar exam if she passes then she's
allowed to continue the apprenticeship
and then she will take the actual
California Bar but her statement was if
I knew more I could do more exactly and
I'm not sure I knew more yeah and just
basically that I wonder however if being
an attorney is that I think somebody
with millions of followers
is literally the influencer of the
century for everyone else you know but
people at this table then I think maybe
she could do more with her attention
rather there the attention on her rather
than this attention but if she knew less
than she would dress less I don't know
one um
thoughts ray if she knew last year the
opposite I would say she's distracting
in the courtroom but I think this is
this to me is like amateur hour and she
had you know she said she was in I think
it was the Roosevelt Room at the White
House with the president with the
lawyers for Alice Johnson she's help all
these people are making powerful to say
I want to know more to me it's it's very
juvenile but you know what she's gonna
have to stick it through as you said a
four-year deal mm-hmm and you know what
let's look at the positive side as you
said Emily she's very influential with
young people who hold her up who admire
her clearly she has now morphed into
somebody who says I want to do more with
my life I really want to have impact on
America and the criminal justice system
golf girl you got you know the idea you
know what's when you're around a good
lawyer
it's a superpower it's like they have
access to stuff you don't that's what
drives you're gonna need one yeah you
need a good lawyer in your life law
school I've heard is like taking three
foreign languages at the same time and
but I would add one thing what if she
knew how she would have more Wow oh
that's pretty good Jesse why don't when
the solution be to teach law in grade
school I can't get over her statement
she's she's trying you think no II you
think knowing more is overrated argue
[Laughter]
200 I think that's the other thing
what would you hire a lawyer that
yes